I think what my team and I have
witnessed in just the last couple of
hours here in Shanghai is really utterly
extraordinary for China we're just going
to take you a bit closer to see the kind
of groups that have gathered here Beyond
where we are just a couple of Roads back
last night were these first flash points
of protests in Shanghai people gathered
people were chanting things that have
almost never really been heard on the
streets of China things like down with
the CCP down with President XI it's
really hard to express just how unusual
this is and so what's happened tonight
is that people have gathered where the
protest was last night and gradually
gradually they have been pushed back by
the police we were in the middle of the
crowd just a bit earlier talking to
people filming them holding up these
white pieces of paper which has become a
symbol of these protests I think we can
show you a few of those um just here now
as well uh they were they were talking
they were crying out free people and
then the police came and they barge
right in through the crowds and they
moved people back some people were
definitely arrested we saw it's very
difficult to say how many but we're
pushed back and back back and now we
have this sort of peaceful Gathering of
people up until the Cordon sort of where
police have moved people back to it's
really really hard to over emphasize
just how incredibly unusual seeds like
this are in mainland China and it's
particularly unusual because it's
happening not just here in Shanghai but
it's happening in a number of cities
across China there have been protests in
the city of Wuhan there have been
protests on University campuses in the
cities of Nanjing and in Beijing as well
um and there is a sense that this
simmering weariness and frustration at
the covid-19 measures is really
beginning to Bubble over and the
Catalyst was this big fire that happened
in the city of arimshi it's many
thousands of miles away from here in the
west of the country 10 people lost their
lives in that fire
um and there is there's feelings and
fears and allegations that the reason
those people died is because
firefighters weren't able to get there
quickly enough and the people weren't
able to leave because of the lockdown
measures and we're trying not to draw
too much attention to ourselves here
because there's a lot of police around
it's not necessarily uh all that safe so
we're a bit careful but
um really extraordinary scenes here in
China